Amsterdam's Rijksmuseum is welcoming
home Rembrandt's the Night Watch left
off at East seven mono the Night Watch
is his most prestigious work competing
with rival group portrait artists he
pulled out all the stops to show what he
could do off today it too is the
societal that can Rembrandt was
commissioned to depict a group of local
militia man for a town hall but he found
the subject boring he wanted more drama
then he feed a p'zone of an bit per
tutti i have to paint a lot of people
and keep it interesting I can work with
light and shadows that way they all look
different depending on the lighting the
doesn't he dug like message benoist it
is since there are two little girls in
the light dressed in yellow one of them
has two chickens on her belt she's going
to sell them they're ready for plucking
engine hangin you come on Oakland you
coming on as as I not these girls must
be market workers a kind of mascot for
the Guild's the Night Watch is
considered the centerpiece of the museum
the 17th century painting was removed
from its original spot 10 years ago
while the museum was refurbished once
the renovation work was finally
completed the move back was an emotional
moment for everyone involved almost like
a reception for royalty the Night Watch
is a landmark work in the history of
Dutch painting and a nation held its
breath as it was transported through the
streets of Amsterdam honest and easy
cash in touch via dns safety is the
absolute priority it's too big to fit
through the door so the building has
special slits allowing the painting to
be moved in its box boy Schmid get our
kisses
the move itself went off without a hitch
the nation celebrated the reopening even
enjoyed some modern style advertising in
the shape of a flash mob at a shopping
mall Rembrandt probably would have liked
it action in motion are pivotal elements
in his paintings unusual for his era
and went when I teach them and as it
Rembrandt was of course Rembrandt and he
conceived of things differently yeah and
he was trying to create a kind of event
on canvas yeah Capitan getting all the
captain gives an order and marches away
and the lieutenant hears it as does the
drummer boy and someone says let's get
going for me even when teasing one makes
this moment when the order is given and
everyone's listening and beginning to
line on in size 10 land besides the
master of the Baroque many other
big-name painters are represented yawn
stain and for mayor
and it's not just the Golden Age of
Flemish painting that's on display the
Reich's museum's collection includes
over 6,500 paintings and 100,000 other
artworks a glass and concrete atrium
leads to the Asian pavilion containing
over 350 exhibits from China Japan and
Indonesia as well as other countries but
the centerpiece of the new museum was
and remains the Night Watch on display
in the gallery of honor Rembrandt spent
some six months working on the painting
but not alone he had a team to help him
come on Tati's together Rembrandt ran
what was pretty much a factory he was so
successful that many art students wanted
to work with that mean if he to shoot on
gtalk you haven't helped out with tasks
such as the primary coat of the canvas
what's a behind most as we go into yet
to the adhan four meters by five
painting had to be tailored to the
dimensions of Amsterdam's Town Hall dog
pasta decoys and a father and he saw
guns in the Night Watch didn't fit the
wall where it was supposed to hang so it
had to be trimmed a little on the side I
finding stonemasons of all afternoon
does better dancer person
today the painting takes pride of place
in the Rijksmuseum it's the only piece
of work to have been returned to its
original position after the renovation
and that is just as it should be